the data for three points on a smooth
function f is given in the table so
let's actually graph these just so that
we can visualize it a little bit
so our vertical axis let's just call
that y is equal to f
of x and then we have our horizontal
axis
we have our horizontal axis this is our
x-axis
and we're going to skip some space here
just because we immediately go to very
high values of
of f of x and i'll even skip some space
here since we already go up to
6.5 all the way up to 7.5 so let me just
show that i'm skipping some space here
and we're going to start let's say this
is 108 108
109 110
and let's say that this right over here
is 6.5
that is 7 and then that is 7.5 and we
can plot these points
6.5 comma 108.25 that will put us right
over there
7 comma 109.45
that puts us right around there
and then 7.5 110.15
puts us right around right around here
and these are just three points on a
smooth function f so we can visualize
what that smooth function f might look
like it might look something
might look something like this try my
best to so maybe it looks
something something like this so
our smooth function f might look
something who knows what it looks like
after this so that's this right over
here is this is the graph of y is equal
to f of x
y is equal to f of x now let's try to
answer their questions what is the
average rate of change of f
with respect to x as x goes from
6.5 to 7 7 to 7.5 and 6.5 to 7.5 so
let's do them one at a time
6.5 to 7. our change in x
our change in x here our change in x
is 7 minus 6.5 which is equal to
0.5 and our change in y here
our change in y here is equal to let's
see we end up at 109.45
minus 108.25 which is 1.2
so our average rate of change over this
interval is our change in y over our
change in x
or 1.2 divided by 0.5 let me write this
down our change in y
over our change in x is equal to 1.2
over
0.5 which is equal to 2.4
so this is equal to 2.4 now let's do the
next interval
our change in x once again is 7.5 minus
6.5 change in x is still 0.5 that's hard
to read let me write that a little bit
neater so our change in x
our change in x is still 0.5
7 to 7.5 and our change in y
our change in y let's see we end up at
110.15 we started at 109.45
so our change is 0.7
so it's 0.7 so our change in y over
change in x
our change in y over change in x is
equal to 0.7 over
0.5 which is equal to 1.4
1.4 and so you can see that the slope of
the secant line this is essentially the
slope of the secant line between
these two points so this one this one
right over here let me try my best to
draw it
this one right over here you can see
it's it's steeper than the second one
then the second one then this secant
line right over here then this
secant line right over there and now
let's find the slope the average rate of
change i should say or the slope of the
secant the average rate of change over
this interval which is the same thing as
the slope of the secant line between
that point and that point
so let's think about our delta x our
delta
x and maybe i'll do it up here so our
delta x we're going from 6.5
to 7.5 so our delta x
is equal to one and what is our delta y
so our delta y our change in y
is equal to let's see we end up at
110.15 we start at 108.25
110.15 minus 108.25
we increase by 1.9
1.9 so our change in y
over change in x is equal to 1.9 over 1
which is equal to 1.9
1.9 fair enough and that's the slope
of this secant line between this point
and this point right over here
slope of the secant line it looks
something like that and you see that
it's
it's slightly less deep than the magenta
secant and it's slightly more steep
than the orin secant it's kind of in
between the two
now they ask us this final question use
the average rate of change of f
on this the larger interval from here to
here which we already figured out that's
1.9
as an approximation for the slope of the
line tangent to f
at x equals seven so we're trying to
approximate the slope of the line
tangent to f at
f equals seven so the line tangent might
look something like this
and we see at least visually it looks
like that that little blue line we drew
this one right over here does look like
it's at least the way i've drawn it
it looks like it's a pretty good
approximation for the slope up there so
we'll use
this as the slope as an approximation
for the slope of the tangent
line at of at two f at x equals seven
they say write an equation of the line
to f at
seven uh write an equation for the line
tangent f at seven
hundred nine point four five using
point-slope form so it's going to be a
line we're going to use this as an
approximation for slope
and it's going to be it's going to
contain this line is tangent it touches
to the curve at this point
and so point-slope form just as a
reminder it's just it's just another way
of saying that every point on this line
every point on this line x comma y
if we were to find the change in x and
change in y relative to this point right
over here
it's always going to have a constant
slope so one way you could say is if you
take an arbitrary point x
y on this line you could say you could
say
your change in y so y minus
109.45 109.45
over your change in x so
we know that the 0.7 is there or the 0.7
is is or the point x what we we can use
x when when f of x when x is equal to 7
f of x is 109.45
so we're referencing the same point when
our change in x is
x minus 7 our change in y is y minus
109.45
and this is always going to be constant
for any xy that i pick on this line
there
and we're using this as an approximation
for what that's going to be
that's going to be equal to 1.9 so if
you want to put it in point slope form
you just multiply both sides times
x minus 7 and you get you get y
minus 109.45
is equal to 1.9 times x
minus 7. and we are done that is
an approximation we've approximated the
slope and if this was the slope this
would be the equation
of the tangent line in point-slope form